guys it is a sad sad day we had to
finally say goodbye to Chad on The
Bachelorette house Gattaca chaz gone
well I'm not because Chad was really
great TV and in true Chad form Chad bear
left us in the most chad way possible by
refusing to apologize sorry if anything
came off on our end but if you want to
take this opportunity to be genuinely
sorry that would be great for all of us
moving on
like I've said all along I'm gonna say
what I want to say what I want to say
but this might be even more dramatic at
the end of the episode we got a sneak
peek at what looks like the finale and
it does not look good I wanted to find
love and I found it with a man that will
not be able to love me in the way that I
said I wanted to be loved
I'm like you're having a book your panic
attack
I fell in love with you and I still love
you but what you did to me it's not
right it's really apart for me to not
accept this love oh okay it looks good
it looks really good just not so good
for Jojo but who do you think she dumps
in the end could it be frontrunner
Jordan Rogers somebody makes her react
in a big way let me know what you think
on Twitter and one last time
Chad goodbye I'm out
you